imagine if we did the Pope is sure to
get worldwide attention even when the
man himself doesn't appear at his own
press conferences his latest encyclical
was inspired by some Francis of Assisi
the pontiff's namesake Safra chairs coil
is mpo some francis is himself an
example of how we should care for a
vulnerable ecology with joy and
authenticity in him we appreciate how
caring for nature fairness towards the
poor engagement in society and interior
peace are inseparable okay punto solo
inseparable II and finally the
long-awaited document the Pope didn't
release it in the usual Latin but in
Italian he wants his thoughts to be
understood by as many people as possible
a day earlier he gave this warning
where's this home of ours is being
ruined and that damages everyone
especially the poor this is an appeal
towards responsibility according to the
duty God gave the human being during
creation his environmental manifesto
runs over 200 pages in it he focuses on
the challenges of global climate change
he takes aim at consumerism and
capitalism problems he says a man-made
francis has called for self-control and
for economies to move away from fossil
fuels to halt global warming and his
thoughts are well timed in december just
a few months away the governments of
almost 200 nations are do together in
Paris to discuss a global agreement on
climate change